مفاجات ماسك والتويتر لا تنتهي اخرها
استبدال شعار العصفور الازرق الى كلب من
سلاله تشيبا اينو خطوه اثارت جدلا واسعا
فما قصه الشعار الجديد صوره الكلب هذه
ترمز للعمله الرقميه المشفره
يعتبر واحده من اشهر الداعمين لهذه العمله
لدرجه انه يسمح لزبائنه بدفع ثمن سيارات
تسلا باستخدام هذه العمله ماسك تغريده
مقتضبه على صفحته بتويتر قال فيها كما
وعدت وارفقها بصوره من تغريدات متبادله
بينه وبين مستخدم اخر طلب منه تغيير شعار
تويتر المعروف الى عمله دوت كوين وبعد هذه
الخطوه بقليل ارتفعت قيمه
في المقابل يواجه الملياردير الامريكي
دعوه وقضائيه من قبل مستثمرين في العمله
بدعوى انه منخرط في مخطط نصب هرمي عن طريق
استخدام عمله دوت كوين المشفره التي تشير
اليها تغريداته للتلاعب باسعارها وهو ما
ينفيه فريق ماسك القانوني